thank you so much for joining us
good afternoon earlier today the
president had the chance to visit a
couple of small businesses here in town
uh one is a locally owned hardware store
that's been around for 150 years
the other which lease is part of the
same space is an urban farm that was
founded just eight years ago
like other small businesses across the
country these companies help serve their
communities
the hardware store sponsors little
league teams and holds events with the
cub scouts
the urban farm serves hundreds of local
households and supplies food
for local farmers markets unfortunately
a lot of companies like this with fewer
than 20 employees
were left out of previous rounds of
small business relief too many mom and
pop businesses and too many
minority-owned businesses were left
behind
while larger well-connected businesses
got funds quickly
the president and the vice president
have made it a top priority to ensure
that this round of small business relief
is distributed more equitably
and that the companies that may not have
gotten relief before have a real shot at
getting relief now
so today we want to share some early
results of how this administration is
already making good
on that commitment on monday february
22nd the president announced important
changes to the paycheck protection
program
which is the primary small business
relief program that the federal
government offers
these changes were intended to ensure
that mom and pop businesses
minority-owned businesses
businesses in rural areas and other
underserved categories of businesses got
the help that they needed
these changes included in instituting a
14-day period
starting on wednesday february 24th
during which only businesses with fewer
than 20 employees could apply
for relief the idea behind the
exclusivity period was to give lenders
time to focus on reaching out to smaller
businesses
including businesses that may not have
that they may not have worked with
before
and to make sure that these smaller mom
and pop shops had their had time to get
their applications in
and improved and at the same time as the
president's announcement the
administration launched
a whole government effort to let small
business owners and lenders know about
this opportunity
the small business administration
launched a series of conversations
reaching thousands of community leaders
through webinars every day white house
officials held
calls with that ended up reaching
thousands of small business owners
directly
and the administration partnered with
congress to help members spread the word
about the changes
and conduct outreach with their
constituents so now we're
reaching the end of the two-week
exclusivity period and the results are
pretty striking
when comparing the data from the
exclusivity period with the 10 days
preceding the exclusivity period
we've seen a significant increase in the
number of loans to the smallest firms
to minority owned and women-owned firms
and to first-time ppp
participants specifically we've approved
more than 300 000 loans for businesses
with fewer than five employees that's a
fifteen percent increase compared to the
pre-exclusivity period
we've approved nearly two hundred
thousand loans to first-time ppp
borrowers which represents a twenty-five
percent increase
there's been a twenty percent increase
in loans to minority-owned businesses
and that translates to an additional 1
000 minority-owned businesses accessing
release
relief every single day of the
exclusivity period
there's been a 14 increase in loans
approved to women-owned businesses
which translates to an additional 600
women-owned businesses accessing relief
every day
and there's been a 12 increase in loans
approved to businesses in rural areas
but that's not all on february 22nd the
president also announced several other
changes to expand access to ppp and as
of last friday the
sba had implemented all of these changes
and we're already starting to see some
early momentum
from those changes as well for example
nearly 30
000 loan applications had previously
been flagged because the small business
owners were delinquent on their federal
student loans
we removed that restriction and can now
advance those applications
and tens of thousands of new
applications have already come in after
we increase the amount of relief
available to sole proprietors
and the self-employed so i want to take
this opportunity to
say to the small business owners out
there there's still plenty of time left
in this program
there's still plenty of money available
to you go to sba.gov
contact your lenders and see if you
qualify for relief
the administration is going to continue
to conduct outreach and spread the world
word about these relief
efforts and what's available to small
businesses but of course our view is
that that's not enough
and that's why the american rescue plan
includes more than 50 billion dollars in
additional aid
for small businesses it provides more
than 28 billion dollars in grants
to support the uh hard hit small
restaurants through the restaurant
revitalization fund
which was a bipartisan proposal in
congress it provides 15 billion
in grants to help the smallest most
severely affected businesses especially
those that serve
lower income areas it provides 10
billion dollars to restore
the successful state small business
credit initiative which leverages
private dollars
to provide working capital to small
businesses and it creates a community
navigator program
so that small business owners can get
help figuring out how to actually get
the relief that they're entitled to even
if they don't have
a team of lawyers and accountants on
call so with that i'm happy to take some
questions
go ahead this is related to something
that we're seeing um on the hill uh and
there
is sort of an increasing movement among
senate democrats
to get extended unemployment insurance
and
uh stimulus checks added to the next uh
buildback better legislation
as you're aware senator durbin has
signed on to it uh and and and they
argue that this is needed to sort of
keep both of these things are needed to
keep people out of poverty
i'm wondering if you agree with that
assertion from an economic
uh standpoint and and what your thoughts
are
well number one the american rescue plan
has been documented by
by several independent experts is
providing a tremendous amount of relief
all by itself to lower income and middle
class families
between the economic impact payments the
checks
the changes to the child tax credit uh
this is there's going to be an
enormous infusion of relief for for
lower income and middle-income families
as you know and as the president has
said this is only step one
step two is to build back better agenda
and i think we're still trying to
think through what the aspects of that
program are going to be we actually we
have received the letter
from the senators who talked about
potentially including uh recurring
relief payments in it we're looking at
the idea
but we're still thinking through the
contours of what's going to be in that
next package
thank you thank you so um earlier today
at the events uh president biden said
that a lot of ppp money went to people
who shouldn't have got it i was hoping
you could
elaborate on that and also i was
wondering if you had any thoughts on
concerns about inflation
you do stimulus bill that's about to be
passed sure so
on uh on one of the president's
statements uh
i believe he was referring to the fact
that in the previous round of ppp
in the previous administration there was
uh documented problems
from the inspector general of the small
business administration that tens of
thousands of companies that were not
eligible
for ppp ended up receiving it in part
that was because the previous
administration did not put any
checks in place on the front end in
other words when the application was
received
to make sure that these were eligible uh
companies
we've changed that there's now
significant
upfront checks to make sure that any
application that's submitted
meets the criteria for for the program
and at the same time that we've
instituted those we still are processing
nearly 100 of applications within 48
hours so we've tried to find the right
balance between
making sure that folks who are not
eligible don't get don't get the relief
but the folks who are eligible get it as
quickly as possible and we think that's
a significant change from the previous
administration
on inflation it's something that as the
president has said as
secretary ellen has said we are
monitoring carefully
you know our belief has been from the
beginning that the risk of doing too
little
to help american families outweigh the
risk of doing too much
um that said we will always be carefully
monitoring
uh inflation and and we will continue to
do so going
of the relief forward vaccines rolling
out a nuclear case could you give us
just a
broad sense of where you think we will
be with the economy at the end of this
year secretary ellen has addressed
employment for 2022 but what about the
forecast for right now
uh so moody's which is an independent
wall street firm projected that
uh the american rescue plan would bring
back roughly seven million additional
jobs by the end of the year
uh you know we we think that that's a
pretty reasonable forecast
there are um as we said there's a
significant amount of relief that is
going out
um to lower income middle-income
families through this bill
as you said the vaccine rollout is
accelerating
obviously that in many ways is the key
to accelerating the economic recovery
um so we're optimistic about that and
and there's good uh
uh credible independent experts that
suggest that we will be
uh making a big big step towards getting
these 10 million jobs that were short
back by the end of the year
low interest rates have made it possible
to finance many of these initiatives
how much debt is too much
well look i think the way to look at it
is uh not in terms of necessarily
the sheer amount of debt but what are
the payments that you have to make
on the debt and that that's why the
interest rates are relevant to this
we are in an extended period of
historically low interest rates and not
to get too wonky but there are some
structural factors that would suggest
that uh interest rates are going to
remain
permanently uh or or there's pressure
keeping them down
over the long term we are carefully
monitoring this
the president has made clear that uh
being fiscally responsible
uh is a priority of his he's also made
clear that
right now uh one of the best things that
we can do
is is deficit finance these investments
because that's what
gets the economy moving more quickly and
in the long term growth helps bring down
the debt and deficit levels as well okay
lesson to bloomberg i promise he'll come
back
we'll probably let him go soon thank you
uh as
the administration considers what
elements are going into the buildback
better plan
some economists have in the white house
to asset a path to citizenship for
some undocumented immigrants including
essential workers be included in that so
can you describe the white house's
current thinking on whether to include
that provision in the plan
um yeah that is a priority of the
presidents i think we have not made a
decision yet on whether to include or
not include that
honestly in the short term we are
focused on trying to get the american
rescue plan into law
and then going out and telling the
american people what was in the american
rescue plan and how it's helping them
uh you know we will continue to work on
um
uh putting together the next step of
this the recovery part of this that the
president has previewed but we're not
quite there yet
thank you so much thank you thank you
okay um
as the president said last week once the
rescue plan is signed
we'll be able to start getting payments
out this month
treasury and irs are working tirelessly
to make that happen
the irs and bureau of the fiscal service
are building on lessons learned from
previous rounds
to increase the number of households
that will get electronic payments
which are substantially faster than
checks and a number of you and obviously
the american people have asked a lot of
good questions about how this process
works so we thought we'd try to answer
some of them uh for households who've
already filed their tax
their income tax return for 2020 the irs
will use that information to determine
eligibility and size of payments
for households that haven't yet filed
for 2020
the irs will review records from 2019 to
determine eligibility and the size of
payment
that includes those who use the
non-filer non-filer portal
for previous rounds of payments which is
a question i think somebody asked
sort of about yesterday for tax returns
with direct deposit or bank account
information
the irs will be able to send money
electronically and for those households
for which treasury cannot determine a
bank account
paper checks or debit cards will be sent
of course we're
not taking anything for granted we're
we're pushing through the finish line
here but
uh you all have asked some really good
questions about the implementation that
we wanted to get ahead of
so here's what this all means for a
typical family of four with parents
making
under 150 000 a year combined and with
kids in school age eight and five
uh because of the president's rescue
plan that family of four will soon be
getting fifty six hundred dollars in
direct payments
and because of the expanded child tax
credit they'll get twenty six hundred
dollars
in addition to that so that's eighty two
hundred dollars more in the pockets of
this family as they try to weather this
storm
on top of additional money in this bill
to reopen schools safely
get shots in arms and help those who've
lost their jobs through no
fault of their own another scheduling
announcement for all of you on friday
morning
uh president biden will meet virtually
with his counterparts in the quad
uh prime minister suga of japan prime
minister modi of india and prime
minister
morrison of australia formed in the
aftermath of the 2004 tsunami
and formalized in 2007 the quad has met
regularly at the working and foreign
minister level
however friday will be the first time
that the quad is meeting at the leader
level
that president biden has made this one
of his earliest
multilateral engagements speaks to the
importance we place on close cooperation
with our allies and partners in the
indo-pacific a range of issues of course
will be discussed
we expect to be discussed i should say
facing the global community
from the threat of krovid to economic
cooperation and of course
the to the climate crisis
earlier today final piece here our covid
coordinator jeff zions
had a weekly governor call with
governors from across the country
he announced pfizer and madonna supply
will get increased to 15.8 million doses
going out to states
tribes and territories along with 2.7
million
first doses going to pharmacies he also
highlighted the progress we've made as a
nation on vaccinations
on january 20th there was a seven day
average
of 890 000 shots per day today we were
averaging 2.17 million shots per day
so it's obviously a significant increase
finally of course reiterated our
commitment to
working collaborating with governors
from both parties and continued and
encouraged continued focus on masking
social distancing while our vaccination
program continues to ramp
up why don't you kick us off thanks um
question on um with the influx of
young people and just migrants in
general to the southern border
is there any sense and i asked this
question with the first
obviously you're only two months into
the administration but
early on you and uh secretary my
orchestra
very much stressed humanity uh and
trying to move away from the
the last administration do you this does
the message need to be tweaked at all
do you need to say that it's not just
about humanity
that also you might not get in or you
probably aren't going to be able to stay
well humanity will always be a value uh
from the president
on down uh but you are right that we are
continuing to work to convey
to people in the region that this is not
the time to come
that the majority of people who come to
the border will be turned away which is
factually accurate and what we're really
talking about in terms of
uh the people who are being let in are
unaccompanied children
that is a policy decision which we made
because we felt it was the most humane
approach
to addressing whatever very difficult
circumstances in the region
and that means there are more children
kids under the age of 18 of course
coming across the border
at this point is this a crisis look i
don't think we need to sit here and put
new
labels on what we have already conveyed
is challenging
what we have conveyed as a top priority
for the president
what our policy teams are working on
every single day
obviously there was a trip to the border
uh this weekend
they are working over the course of
every day uh since then on
putting in place policies that can help
address what we're seeing and and help
ensure that we are uh keeping these kids
safe and moving them as quickly as
possible from
border patrol facilities to uh to
shelters where they can have access to
educational resources
health resources mental health resources
legal aid etc go ahead
follow up on that thanks um there are
reports out there that the number of
unaccompanied migrants has at the border
has tripled in the last two weeks to
3200
plus is that number accurate i'm not
going to confirm numbers from here
obviously the department of homeland
security and others are oversee the
programs and the engagements that happen
at the border
i will say that there are a couple of
reasons i know um are asked about
our kind of change in policy but there
are a couple of reasons
why we think people are coming to the
border of course
individuals are fleeing countries where
individuals and families are
you know they're fleeing prosecution
fleeing violence fleeing economic
hardships and other things
the region has also experienced two
hurricanes in the fall
putting further stress on the conditions
in these countries and the circumstances
that are facing individuals and all this
is taking place during a global pandemic
that has impacted other countries
economies placing undue hardships on its
people just as it did
in the united states so there are also a
range of factors that are leading
individuals to come to the border why
won't you confirm that number that's a
very important number
i i i we've been very clear that there
is an
increase that there are more children
coming across the border
than we have facilities for at this
point in time uh those numbers are
tracked by the department of homeland
security so i'm certainly
i'm just suggesting that you talk to
them about specifics then jen they won't
confirm the numbers
well i would encourage you to go back to
them and ask them again we're not going
to confirm them from the white house
it's not our program it's the department
of homeland
department is the white house
encouraging the department to release
those numbers and in the spirit of
transparency that the secretary promised
here at this point
we certainly encourage transparency but
what i also think is important is to
talk about what the root causes are here
and what we're doing from a policy
standpoint to try to address
the challenges uh that we're facing and
that these kids are facing as they come
across the border
relief should we expect to see the
president travel to perhaps after he
signs this bill
uh to highlight the benefits after the
american rescue
plan is signed uh we certainly recognize
that we can't just uh sign a bill again
we're we're not taking anything for
granted we're getting across the finish
line but
uh that we will need to do some work and
use our best
voices including the president the vice
president and others to
communicate to the american people the
benefits of this package how they can
benefit from the package
how they can have access to checks part
of the reason i wanted to do that
at the top uh how it will help schools
reopen and so
i think you can certainly expect the
president to be doing some travel and
we'll have more details on that in the
coming days
absolutely go ahead now you talked about
the need of getting these
uh 3000 or so potentially children out
of the
um border patrol facilities and into hhs
facilities that are meant to house
children
how quickly can that be done and what is
being done right now to make sure it
happens sure
let me walk you through a little bit of
what the considerations are and what our
team is working on
now so um first um
the reason why these kids are being let
in i've talked about that a bit
but the majority of people come to the
border are still turned away or expelled
under title 42. so
families adults etc we're talking about
children i'm just level setting here
when children are apprehended at the
border they are initially processed as
you've noted through customs and border
patrol facilities
where they are held until they can be
sent to hhs shelters
where the children have access to
education services medical and mental
health services we've talked about this
a little bit but just to reiterate
the reason why one of the challenges
we've had is that covet 19
the pandemic had initially severely
limited the amount of children
that could be taken into hhs facilities
and the pace at which that could happen
so one of our focuses is on working on
seeing how we can address that that
includes looking at additional
facilities
it includes there were some cdc
guidelines that was
that were released on friday and those
guidelines for hhs facilities will allow
capacities to be returned to
pre-covered numbers all while taking
other steps like increased ventilation
additional masking and other member
measures to continue to keep these
children safe so one of the things we're
doing
is implementing working to implement
these recommendations so that we can
ensure there are more kids who can be
safely
in these facilities we are also as i
noted uh working to expedite
um we're looking at additional
facilities where we can safely
house children and ensure they have
access to all of the resources that i
noted
and finally we're also looking for ways
that we can expedite
uh the way that we we vet and process
families and sponsor host families
where these kids can go because of
course once they go from cbp facilities
which we are working to expedite that
we don't want them to be in these cbp
facilities we want them to be in
shelters as quickly as possible and then
ultimately
we want them to be in families and homes
where
their applications can be uh can be
processed
but we are looking to expedite the way
that we um
consider uh the way that we vet families
and sponsor homes
as well and last week you weren't ready
to confirm that
new facilities might be brought online
including perhaps
fort lee in virginia or homestead
florida can you give us
any new details about how many new
facilities might be repurposed and how
quickly
it's a good question i don't have
anything to confirm for you in terms of
new facilities we are looking at
facilities
a lot of considerations underway and
certainly part of the reason is
where we want to have more kids able to
transfer from cbp facilities
to hhs facilities so the cdc guidelines
helped us ensure there are more kids
able to have safely in a lot of these
facilities but
also we're looking at facilities but no
decisions have been made at this point
can you tell us anything about any
diplomatic efforts that are taking place
between the biden administration and the
central american countries
to find ways to deter some of these
children from coming to the border it's
a great question and it's a key part of
our strategy
i've actually asked roberta jacobson if
she could come join us in the briefing
room so we hope to do that
sooner rather than later um because
those are great questions that i think
she would be an excellent person to
address
but in the meantime no information about
any conversations that are taking place
between the u.s and the
sure well all i was conveying is a
commitment to get you
an even an expert that can that is
involved in these discussions who can
help answer your questions but
uh and i also conveyed that it is a key
priority for us and that there are
conversations going on
at a number of levels obviously through
our national security team through the
state department
about the importance of conveying
clearly this is not the time to come
working with countries on how we can
address the root causes as
as you know but everyone may not know
one of the key proposals in the
president's immigration bill
is additional funding to address the
root causes and that's something we're
certainly communicating about so
but i think what i heard from you is
specific questions about engagements
a lot of those would be read out from
the state's apartment but i've invited
roberta to come and we'll look forward
to having her here soon
go ahead hey so airlines have been
urging the
administration to develop guidelines for
a travel passport so
americans can begin traveling the
country again is that something
the administration is considering doing
and do you think it's a good idea for
the government to
make those kind of guidelines vaccine
passports i believe they are calling it
right
uh well we recognize that as many
americans get vaccinated
questions will come up and they're
already starting to come up as to how
people will be able to demonstrate they
are vaccinated i think it's important to
remember only about 10
of the american population is vaccinated
at this point uh
we've obviously made progress but we
have more work to do and right now our
our focus as the us government is on
getting
more people vaccinated and we'll think
about how people can demonstrate
they are vaccinated as we get more
people vaccinated but that's where we're
putting our energy and resources toward
we also know that the private sector as
as you noted in your question is is
concerned and has raised this and
uh and we believe they and
not-for-profits will be uh driving this
initiative uh and all likelihood moving
forward
so it sounds like the administration
doesn't want to get involved in setting
the standards for what would qualify
someone for a vaccine passport well i
think a vaccine passport is something
that's been designated by the
or an idea coming from the airlines what
i'm conveying is
there are lots of ideas that will come
from the private sector nonprofits
we we welcome those but our focus from
the federal government is on
getting more people vaccinated and
that's where we feel we can use our
resources best
another subject uh there's a report
today on the south china morning post
that
the us and china are trying to set up
some sort of high-level diplomatic
meeting
in alaska to try and reset relations is
that any kind of meeting like that
under is that being planned or is that
under consideration
right now i have heard or seen those
those reports
um i don't have anything to report out
to you obviously the president spoke
with president xi
ju back february 10th and we will uh
look forward to
seeking opportunities for engagement but
we don't have any details uh
finalized or confirmed at this point is
there any uh
further updates on the website you can
ask them
not the website okay you can you can i
was ready i'll save that one for next
one okay
uh but on on for possibly next week is
the president uh
chosen a date yet or working with
congress on a joint address to congress
and what's that going to look like as
far as being virtual or in person
uh i don't have any update on that for
you and certainly as soon as we have a
date confirmed we are looking forward to
doing a joint address we're working
through that with congress
our focus now is on uh the address the
president will be delivering on thursday
night during his first primetime address
he'll talk about covid what we've
been through as a country and what the
path forward looks like and we'll focus
on
the next address once we get through
that go ahead caitlin a few questions
for you but one on the stimulus checks
we're talking about
who is getting them you've you and the
president have both said that they're
going to be going out this month but the
last round they went out pretty quickly
i think within a few days so do you know
any more specific timing on when people
should
expect them it's something our treasury
team is
working on uh and and working to
expedite of course and that's a priority
to the president
one of the steps they're taking is
working to ensure more people can get
them electronically because that of
course speeds it up
so let me actually just give you because
i have a little bit more detail here
caitlyn um in terms of how it will work
um so the first batch of payments will
go to all taxpayers who provided direct
deposit in their 2019 or 2020 returns
followed by taxpayers who didn't provide
that information but for whom the irs
has
payment information from other programs
uh and of course
as the president said once the bill is
passed we'll be able to start getting
these payments out this month but in
terms of more specifics we're
waiting for them to get all their
systems in place and then we'll hope to
have an update
and any update on whether or not he
wants his signature on there like former
president trump demanded
well we are we are doing everything in
our power to expedite the payments and
not delay them which is why the
president's name
will not appear on the memo line of this
round of stimulus checks
the checks will be signed by a career
official at the bureau of fiscal
service this is not about him this is
about the american people getting relief
almost 160 million of them so did he did
not want his name to appear on the
checks
he didn't think that was a priority or a
necessary step his focus was on getting
them out as quickly as possible
okay thank you and on immigration uh you
said you wanted to stay away from labels
i know the the dhs secretary has not
wanted to call it a crisis but instead
referred to as a challenge
but right now since it is 3 200
unaccompanied migrant children according
to documents from monday
that's higher than the peak of the 2019
border crisis when it was around 2600
then and at that period there were kids
sleeping on floors they were overcrowded
facilities
so when his delegation traveled there
did they see that people sleeping on
floors and overcrowded facilities
well first one of the reasons is because
there we have a different policy than
the last administration we're not
turning kids away at the border
unaccompanied children
um we're also of course not ripping them
from the arms of their parents
and so we know and we that we knew we
know there is going
to be an increased number of kids coming
across the border there are several
steps as we've talked about a little bit
that we're working
to address that uh the team of course uh
we put out a readout of their
meeting they are going to do a meeting
of course and and give the president a
full rundown of
uh what they saw on the ground a trip
they that he asked them to take and i'll
let them do that before we
uh have more specifics and we of course
are committed to uh ensuring there's
transparency and
access uh for cameras to the facility as
well so do we have a timeline on that on
when reporters will actually be able to
go in and see because that was kind of
that was what was so helpful last time
yeah showing people what it looked like
inside there so
is that going to happen within the next
week or is it going to be
pushed further down the road than that
when can cameras actually get inside
those facilities we're committed to
doing that i don't have a timeline
for you at this point in time we want to
do it uh with respect for
the privacy of the people staying there
uh people who are
being housed there but also uh abiding
by covet protocols and so
we're working through some of those
steps okay my last question is did
president biden agree that the travel
restrictions should not be
changed for people who are fully
vaccinated like the cdc the cdc
guidelines
that was a determination made by the cdc
it wasn't a
uh driven by or directed by the white
house and
as uh as rochelle dr wolenski has said
it's just a first step and
as more people are vaccinated they'll
look at ways to ease
additional restrictions but there were
some reasons as she outlined that
travel was not a part of this according
to what the health and medical experts
who are working at the cdc determined
which includes the impact of travel you
know 10
of the population is is vaccinated 90 is
not
it still remains of course uh it still
is a concerning
uh a concern there's still concerning
impact of travel on people who are not
vaccinated
and also because we are still tracking
and looking at the impact of variance
so they will look at all these factors
this again was just a first step on
guidelines as she has said
and i'm sure they'll look at a range of
factors as they've committed to
as more people in the country are
vaccinated go ahead
thanks john couple questions um to
follow up on the border why has this
administration
been so reluctant to call it a crisis
with a huge
uptick in the number of migrants being
detained including thousands of children
if that doesn't qualify as a crisis what
does well because we think that it's
most important to explain the
substantive policy of what's happening
uh what the root causes are of why these
kids are coming
and why what we're doing to try to solve
what is
a very challenging circumstance at the
border and that's the information the
american people are looking for so
that's what we're working to provide on
a different note can you clarify for us
uh what happened with the president's
dogs or some reports that
one of them was involved in a fighting
incident can you clarify exactly
what happened sure uh champion major the
president
and first ladies dogs are members of the
family
are still getting acclimated and
accustomed to their new surroundings
and new people and on monday the first
family's younger dog
major was surprised by an unfamiliar
person
and reacted in a way that resulted in a
minor injury to the individual
which was handled by the white house
medical unit with no further treatment
needed
it had been previously planned already
for the dogs to be cared for by family
friends in delaware during dr biden's
travels
to military bases this week she has a
three-day trip this week
and the dogs will return to the white
house soon
go ahead sabrina thank you jen uh two
questions for you
first off house democrats are preparing
to bring back earmarks as part of an
effort to build support for
infrastructure legislation
does president biden support the return
of earmarks and are there specific
restrictions that he would seek to
prevent the kind of abuse
that has occurred in the past sure well
we don't have an infrastructure bill yet
don't even know that it will be an
infrastructure bill and in terms of what
it will look like and what the
negotiations will require we are
happy to have that conversation uh when
it's uh when it's appropriate but right
now we're focused on the american rescue
plan so
i'm not going to get ahead of the
legislative strategy for a future bill
position on earmarks more broadly i
don't think anything has changed about
his position he obviously was in
congress for 36 years
but in terms of what it will look like
or what restrictions would be on a new
package i'm sure he'll hear from and
we'll eager to listen to
members of both parties and about their
views on this issue and
we'll certainly factor it in as we put
together a new uh his next step in the
buildback better agenda second question
the indian government has threatened to
jail employees at facebook and twitter
if they do not comply with the
government's data requests or requests
that they take down
accounts associated with these farmers
protests that have been ongoing
for months now what is the
administration's view of a foreign
government threatening to jail employees
at u.s companies well certainly we
believe in freedom of speech freedom of
press freedom of expression
and it is a concern that the president
and others at the highest
level raise at every opportunity uh even
with allies with
adversaries uh and uh but in terms of
specific conversations about this i
expect the state department would be
closest to those engagements
go ahead karen um some questions on the
cdc guidelines yesterday
it's obviously very big news for
families yes but the message
that we heard from officials was all
about families you didn't hear anything
about school reopening tied to these
guidelines
if vaccinated grandparents can be with
their unvaccinated children
without masks how do you apply that same
standard
to schools well these guidelines or i
don't want to get over my skis here as a
non i am not a doctor
but these guidelines were very specific
to the
to what uh recommendations made for
people's homes right so
karen you and your husband and your kids
can you know
engage with and have dinner with your
neighbors when everybody's vaccinated
that is certainly a positive step
forward for many many many americans
these were not guidelines for a
workplace whether it is the white house
or a business or a school there were
guidelines provided of course for
schools and i think the cdc is sees it
as
imperative that they take different
circumstances with different
um looking at the the very specific uh
engagements the number of people the
risks as they factor in
what guidelines they're going to put
forward when can we see guidelines as
more people get vaccinated
than applied to schools or applied to
workplaces with these same standards
well uh they will continue to review as
dr wolinski has said
as more people are vaccinated uh there's
a greater opportunity to
make recommendations that will allow
people to spend time together
to hug grandparents cousins teachers
and certainly that's all of our hope but
they look at all the factors
including the impact of variance as
she's taught as she talked about when
she rolled this out
and uh and and make recommendations
based on how to keep the public safe
and you know there is a concern that has
been raised by all of our medical
experts about not
taking our foot off the gas here we are
we are close
relatively so given the last year we've
been through and
they put out these guidelines because
they feel comfortable that
uh you know about the data they have as
it relates to vaccinated individuals
but of course they need to continue to
analyze data
look at health and medical advice talk
to the doctors at the cdc
before they make additional
recommendations it's vaccinated how will
he change his behavior based on these
guidelines will he see grandkids more
will he see family in a different way
than he was doing
before these guidelines came out you
know of course the president abides by
the
cdc guidelines as no one would it would
uh be expected to hear
um but he also believes he needs to be a
model for
the american people and all citizens i
haven't this is a great question i
haven't talked to him about how it will
impact him
personally in that way i'm happy to
venture to do that or all of you could
ask him next time you have the
opportunity
uh but i noted that and this was a good
question uh someone asked i think
over the last 24 hours about how it
impacts us
here and you know the white house is a
place of work right it is not
a private home and so we will continue
to wear masks we will continue to be
tested we will continue to
socially distance until our health and
medical experts
tell us otherwise go ahead in the back
thank you jen
so two follow-up follow-ups and then a
couple of questions
first the follow-ups um about the quad
uh virtual meeting can we see this as a
as a prelude to re-engaging
the tpp
i wouldn't see it as a direct connection
to that no this is an opportunity to
engage at a engage at a newbie
engage at a high level at an even higher
level than has been
done in the past with key partners to
the united states
japan australia they're they're key
partners uh to the united and india
sorry
they're key partners to the united
states there's a range of issues to
to discuss and work together on uh
whether it's addressing the climate
crisis whether it's
uh working together to address the
global pandemic or of course economic
cooperation but
i wouldn't see it through this prison
the president has been clear about
his commitment to rebuilding the middle
class and looking at any
engagement trade engagement through that
prism um okay thank you
as for jordan's story uh question about
the uh
uh the south china morning post uh
eventual discussion and anchorage i have
a uh
my colleague from um kyoto news the
japanese
news agency is asking how will the biden
more broadly how how will the biden
administration plan to
engage with the chinese are derrick
talks under consideration
direct talks with the chinese well i
mean the president has spoken with
president xi
already so of course we remain engaged
directly um through at a range of levels
uh
and that will continue
like a summit type of event i'm not here
to predict a summit uh
of course there'll be a range of
engagements that the president and his
national security ability
team will have with china and other
countries in the region in the
months and years ahead but we are
directly engaged
there are a range of issues we of course
have talked with the chinese
about through those engagements uh we
don't hold back about our concerns but
we also
uh look for opportunities to work
together just
a week actually eight days precisely
before
the the president entered the white
house the previous administration
um and put cuba
back on the list of state sponsors of
terrorism
does the president share this view
uh well we've talked about this um a
little bit in here before
and nothing's really changed but i'm
happy to reiterate our policy
um our policy as it relates to cuba will
be governed by two principles first
support for democracy and human rights
will be at the core of our efforts
through empowering the cuban people to
determine their own futures
uh second americans especially cuban
americans are the best ambassadors for
freedom
and prosperity in cuba a cuba policy
shift is not
currently among president biden's top
priorities
but we are committed to making human
rights a core pillar of our u.s policy
and we're committed to carefully
reviewing policy decisions made in the
prior administration including
the decision to designate cuba as a
state sponsor of terrorism
very very last question go ahead it's
about the border
okay you keep repeating this is not the
time to come
will there be it is not sending the
signal that there will be a time to come
just wait
well first to be clear even these
unaccompanied children who come across
the border group we've talked about we
want to keep safe we want to ensure they
are in
shelters where there is access to
educational services legal services
health services
we want to ensure that they are then
quickly moved to vetted families or
sponsor homes
many of them don't stay because they go
through the process
of having their applications reviewed um
we just want to keep them safe because
they are kids under the age of 18.
uh and when we say it's not the time to
come now the reason is
this is a we are still digging our way
out of a
dismantled immoral and ineffective
immigration
policy that was being implemented by the
last administration that was largely
based around
funding for a border wall it's going to
take us some time
and we do want to put in place and
modernize the immigration system
which means investing in smart security
which means creating a pathway
to citizenship which means funding and
supporting efforts to address the root
causes
in the region and we as a part of that
we want to ensure that there is
effective processing
at the border we are not trying to close
our borders we are trying to keep
create an effective moral humane system
it's going to take some time to do that
go ahead uh thank you jen i'd like to
ask about three things that's okay the
dogs immigration and then governor
another dog's question okay
go ahead just a quick clarification on
the dogs okay um can you confirm that it
was a secret service member who was
bitten
and can you also reassure the public
that major biden will not be euthanized
as a result of this
well certainly major biden is a member
of the family so i can assure you that
i don't have any more details on the
individual i would encourage you to ask
the secret service but i'm not going to
have any more
details other than that then on
immigration
you've said repeatedly now is not the
time to come but you've also
noted there's a distinction for
unaccompanied minors that they're all
being allowed in
um i want to revisit something the
secretary mayorka said last week he said
that
loving parents end quote uh we're
sending nine-year-old children alone
um of course there are frequent there's
frequently fiscal and sexual abuse for
migrants on in
in transit and also in u.s custody uh
so i was hoping to drill down on the
messaging there uh do you think it's
important to send the message to
children unaccompanied children that now
is not the time to come and to their
parents that it's not a
quote loving act to send them i think
it's imperative that we send the message
that this is a dangerous journey
children don't make it they experience
very difficult circumstances
on the journey now the circumstances in
a lot of these countries is such that
the parents feel that
taking that risk is better than the
circumstances they're living through
but we are very clear about this message
in the region
that this is not the time to come that
this is a dangerous journey
uh that we of course are focused on
modernizing our immigration system
uh and and making it a system that can
better process
uh people at the border uh make it more
humane we are going to abide by our laws
and continue to
implement those laws but i can assure
you that message is being sent clearly
in the region so now is not the time to
come for children as well
correct the governor cuomo question
uh you've been asked this uh many times
about his uh the sexual
harassment allegations against him i
just wanted to confirm that you have
spoken with both president biden and
vice president harris about the
allegations
yes and i've reiterated on their behalf
that uh they believe all women should be
heard
uh that they should be treated with
respect uh they
there's an independent investigation as
all of you know that is being led by the
attorney general who named i believe
some individual lawyers will be in
charge of that today if i'm if i'm
reading reports correctly
uh and certainly they respect that and
believe that should move forward